meet the men going for roses on Jojo
season of The Bachelorette I literally
feel like that didn't add a magic yep
that's exactly what we're gonna need if
these guys want us to buy their job
descriptions
there's Brandon a hipster James s a
bachelor superfan and Daniel his career
being Canadian I just met the girl I'm
gonna marry these sneak peek photos
prove the men pull out all the stops to
make a memorable first impression we've
got a guy in a kilt Santa oh and don't
forget the unicorn and then there's
Jordan Rogers now look at you I'm like a
former pro quarterback and a brother of
Super Bowl MVP Aaron Rodgers he's 27 and
a rumored frontrunner the youngest guys
are 26 the oldest is 34
Jojo by the way is 25 also in the
category of are they here for the right
reasons there's a radio DJ a barber a
bartender and this guy Evan an erectile
dysfunction expert who's also a single
dad raising three boys yep we cannot
make this stuff up I cannot wait for the
season to start that's weird the
Bachelorette and it starts the 23rd on
ABC and I also want to find out how many
of those guys that Jojo ends up getting
romantic with that fantasy suite right
yes and most of them